[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue très heureux de
vous retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 10 janvier voici les
titres
raphaël cogner démissionne le maire de
mantes la jolie a fait connaître sa
décision vendredi soir au préfet des
yvelines ultime épisode du conflit qui
l'oppose au président du conseil
départemental et élu municipal pierre
bédier de nouvelles élections vont se
tenir prochainement le détail et les
réactions à suivre le retour d'un
équipement pour le sud yvelines le
centre aquatique les fontaines a rouvert
samedi à rambouillet cela faisait cinq
ans que ce site était fermé pour travaux
sur place désormais trois bassins dont
vont pouvoir profiter les habitants des
36 communes de rambouillet territoire
et puis c'est encore la période vous le
voyez pour se séparer de son sapin après
les fêtes à maisons-laffitte la
municipalité procède à une collecte
écologique en calèche à un dispositif
que la cité du cheval a mis en place
depuis lé 2018
dans cette édition également le mal être
actuel des soignants de l'hôpital mignot
du chesnay rocancourt une mobilisation
silencieuse s'est tenue vendredi dernier
elle va se poursuivre on en parle tout à
l'heure avec mon invité après plusieurs
semaines de tension le maire de
mantes-la-jolie raphaël cogner a donc
remis sa démission au préfet des
yvelines de nouvelles élections auront
lieu d'ici à trois mois explication dans
ce sujet de maths ile de france après
plusieurs mois d'affrontements avec le
président du département des yvelines la
coupe est pleine pour raphaël cogné le
maire de mantes-la-jolie a remis sa
démission au préfet des yvelines qui l'a
accepté samedi 8 janvier mon sentiment
c'est un double sentiment le premier
c'est la tristesse parce qu'on quitte
pas ses fonctions de maire sans
tristesse c'est une fonction qui est
absolument passionnante et qui nous met
en contact des gens et puis en même
temps un très grand soulagement parce
que la situation politique depuis 18
septembre et la guerre déclenchée par
charlie était devenu impossible à mantes
la jolie beaucoup de mes amis
on souhaitait démissionner parce qu'il
ne supportait plus le blocage auxquelles
nous étions confrontés effectivement
face à cette situation de nombreux élus
ont décidé de démissionner le conseil
municipal n'étant pas suffisamment
complet pour élire un nouveau maire des
élections seront donc organisées d'ici à
trois mois les mantes et devront alors
retrouvé les urnes pour élire leur
nouveau maire parmi les potentiels
candidats jean luc santini ancien
adjoint à l'urbanisme et soutien
infaillible des pierre bédier
effectivement dès que nous aurons la
date précise des élections et qu'on
pourra déposer les listes je déposerai
bien une liste en tant que tête de liste
avec au minimum les 30 les 30 élus qui
me suivent sur la liste actuelle et qui
sont des élus sortants et pour moi
raphaël était le maire pour les pour les
20 ans à venir on se rend compte
aujourd'hui au goût de robes ou de
plusieurs plusieurs mois que ça ne
fonctionne pas qu'il n'ait pas c'est pas
un homme d'action il est charmant gentil
il parle probablement bien mieux que moi
ça c'est évident par contre c'est pas un
homme d'action il ne prend pas de
décision mais la guerre est loin d'être
finie puisque jean-luc santini sera
certainement confronté à l'ancien maire
de mantes-la-jolie qui n'a pas dit son
dernier mot et souhaite se relancer dans
la bataille des municipales
les gens vous savez ils me disent
quelque chose de très simple ils nous
disent monsieur le maire on a compté
pour vous seuls nous avons le pouvoir de
vous faire partir et le fait que les
choses se passent de cette façon a été
vécue comme une blessure pour moi mais
aussi par la population qui à juste
titre parle d'un scandale démocratique
ce matin j'ai reçu cinq messages de gens
disant monsieur le maire j'ai vu une
autre vidéo je veux venir sur baptiste
donc je vous dis le calendrier sera très
important mais moi clairement je n'aurai
pas de mal à boucler une liste et je
pense que je pourrais même en faire
d'autres d'autres listes vont
probablement saisir cette opportunité le
parti communiste de menthe mené par marc
jamet propose déjà une liste de
rassemblement à gauche autour de trois
axes la solidarité le retour du social
et le développement des services publics
et c'est automatique raphaël cogner net
également plus le président de grand
paris seine et oise la communauté
urbaine c'est la première vice
présidente cécile zammit popescu
également maire de meulan divine qui va
assurer l'intérim à la tête de gps et au
et ce jusqu'à la date du 20 janvier où
va se tenir un nouveau conseil
communautaire qui servira à élire le
nouveau président de la communauté
urbaine toujours à mantes-la-jolie ce
drame qui s'est noué samedi après-midi
après 13 heures dans le quartier du val
fourré une fillette de 3 ans a chuté du
deuxième étage d'un immeuble de la rue
clément ader seul au moment des faits
elle aurait ouvert la fenêtre de
l'appartement avant de basculer par
dessus le balcon l'enfant a été conduit
dans un état grave à l'hôpital necker à
paris son pronostic vital n'est pas
engagé mais son état de santé restait
préoccupant ce week end une enquête est
ouverte sur les circonstances de cette
chute le parent chargé de la
surveillance de la fillette se serait
absenté vraisemblablement pour aller
chercher un autre enfant
[Musique]
alors que les chiffres du coffee 19
continuent leur hausse inquiétante et
que dans le même temps le nombre de
nouvelles hospitalisations quotidienne
augmente aussi les soignants de
l'hôpital public tire la sonnette
d'alarmé et des mobilisations se
tiennent partout en france assez
régulièrement au centre hospitalier de
versailles l'hôpital andré mignot du
chesnay rocancourt une partie des
soignants c'est par exemple réuni
vendredi on en parle avec mon invité le
docteur catherine à z man bonsoir
qui est avec moi par visioconférence
vous êtes pédiatre au centre hospitalier
de versailles avant de parler du
mal-être de laurent blanc dit de vos
revendications sur la forme vous avez
observé une minute de silence donc
vendredi à 14 heures et vous prévoyez
est de refaire de le refaire chaque
vendredi à la même heure pourquoi
justement vous faire entendre par le
silence pourquoi le choix de cette
action
il ya eu beaucoup d'action dans le bruit
avec beaucoup de casseroles beaucoup de
choses qui ont essayé de mobiliser les
esprits et faire entendre nos
gouvernants que l'hôpital n'allait pas
bien que nous étions inquiets que les
soignants était fatigué et il n'y a pas
eu de réponse sur le terrain au
quotidien nous n'avons pas vu un terme
et lioration de notre qualité de travail
la prise en charge des patients donc on
a décidé c'est une mouvement national de
mobilisation qui a été initié à
strasbourg avant les fêtes et qui
regroupe beaucoup beaucoup d'hôpitaux de
plus en plus je crois que nous sommes à
peu près une trentaine de centres
hospitaliers à faire cette action donc
maintenant ça sera tous les vendredi à
14 heures une minute de silence devant
l'hôpital mignot donc tous les hôpitaux
de france de lille à bordeaux à rennes à
caen à strasbourg bien sûr colmar
marseille etc en espérant que cette
minute de silence fasse plus de bruit
que tout le bruit qu'on n'a pu faire
depuis pour signaler le malaise de
l'hôpital public il ya un drame pour se
faire entendre il ya un vrai un vrai
malaise vous le dit aujourd'hui
saturation des services un personnel
vous le disiez aussi fatigué aujourd'hui
un personnel fatigue et un personnel là
un personnel plus tellement révolte un
personnel qui va mal et parce que le
travail est de plus en plus difficile on
a l'impression de mal faire on a
l'impression qu'en moi par exemple je
m'occupe de maladies chroniques de
diabète de l'enfant j'ai mon travail de
diabétologues je prends en charge des
enfants et si quelqu'un est absente
d'urgence et bien je dois aller le
remplacer en plus de mon travail et j'ai
l'impression pas bien faire ni l'un ni
l'autre et pour mes collègues c'est la
même chose tous les jours tous les jours
nos cadres gère des arrêts maladie des
gens à la fois qu'ils ont commis bien
sûr actuellement et puis des personnels
qui en ont assez de mal faire qui
veulent partir et qui quittent l'hôpital
pour aller soit ailleurs soit changer
complètement de vie donc acte personnel
ça veut dire des lits fermer des lits
fermés ça veut dire pour les urgences
pas de lits d'aval c'est à dire une
grosse saturation des services d'urgence
et donc à une dynamique qui est vraiment
dans une spirale infernale vers le bas à
la dynamique qui se répercute sur
l'ensemble des services vous parlez d
urgence aujourd'hui une ceinture il ya
une saturation de l'ensemble des
services à l'hôpital
le mal est surtout visible aux urgences
en août où les gens arrivent parce que
le service des urgences et services on
peut se faire soigner 24 heures sur 24
ou les plateformes de on peut faire une
radio un bilan biologique 24 heures sur
24 en ville n'y a plus cette scène c'est
de cette possibilité et est même
maintenant les gens qui ont peu vite
peuvent être amenés à venir à l'hôpital
pour faire un test pour en l'avion ce
qui est absolument pas le rôle de
octobre
je pense que l'hôpital public tenait sur
les bonnes volontés de ses personnels on
a beaucoup travaillé pendant ces années
covin on a été fatigué on a travaillé
parfois quinze jours de suite voir
maintenant parfois on travaille trois
semaines de suite sans s'arrêter et on a
beaucoup donné je pense que les
personnels sont fatigués et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la bonne prise en charge
des patients la plus optimale possible
ne peut être assurée vous lisiez au vu
de ces conditions
c'est à dire par exemple en pédiatrie en
prenant de mon domaine de travail quand
des vies sont fermés on ne peut pas
hospitaliser les enfants c'est une
évidence donc en fait les enfants qui
normalement de fait est hospitalisé
parce qu'ils sont une crise d'asthme
sévère parce que il y on voudrait les
surveiller parce qu'ils ont 15 jours un
mois un mois et demi ils ont beaucoup de
fièvre on ne peut pas les hospitaliser
donc on peut les transférer dans
d'autres hôpitaux à dreux à evreux oms
et des transferts très très loin parce
que il ya des lits fermés faute de
personnel ça c'est inadmissible en 2022
en france d' inadmissibles cette
situation elle existait déjà avant cette
crise sanitaire elle s'est aggravée avec
la situation sanitaire oui bien sûr elle
s'est aggravée être la situation parce
que les personnels ou quitter l'hôpital
l'hôpital n'est plus attractif l'hôpital
n'est plus attractif non pas qu'il ne
travaille pas bien je pense que nous
faisons un très très bon travail
taminiaux en particulier j'y suis mais
on a l'impression que ça on peut pas
travailler en prenant note en expliquant
mois m'occupant de maladies chroniques
par exemple le diabète n'est pas bien
entre guillemets payer il ne rapporte
pas d'argent à l'hôpital donc il faut
prendre du temps pour expliquer un une
maman ou un papa d'un bébé de 18 mois
qu'est ce que c'est que le diabète les
piqûres donc ça ça prend du temps mais
c'est pas du tout valorisé à l'hôpital
public et l'argent étant le nerf de la
guerre on se retrouve confronté à des
problèmes de personnel et conséquence
oui c'est la dégradation des conditions
de travail
des conséquences également sur le
personnel soignant qui est fatigué et
qui est même année vous le disiez à
partir soit vers le privé soit même à
changer de voie professionnelle et dans
le même temps c'est ce que vous avanciez
à l'instant c'est difficile de recruter
aussi dans ce secteur il ya peu de que
des gens sont appelés à 7 et rieur
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de cv c'est à
dire que je pense que nos cadres ne
reçoivent pas de s'élever pour recruter
du personnel nous en tant que médecin on
voit il peut y avoir des grossesses ou
des arrêts maladie on ne peut pas
répéter des médecins comme ça tu un jour
à l'autre on le sait il faut dix ans
pour faire un médecin même plus et on
n'a pas pensé le numerus clausus c'était
une grosse erreur des gouvernements
précédents ça n'est pas la faute du
gouvernement actuel et c'est pas le
propos mais on va recruter ailleurs
alors que notre propre enfant ne
pourront pas faire médecine avec un
numerus clausus très très très sévères
et il va falloir du temps pour recruter
et faire que le personnel soit
suffisamment
à abondants on va dire par rapport à ce
qu'on pourrait faire un bon travail le
ségur de la santé qui a été avancé par
le gouvernement pour répondre justement
assez à thurey cette urgence dans le
monde de la santé qui prévoit des
hausses de salaires pour les soignants
des enveloppes aussi attribué aux
hôpitaux on parle de 75 millions d'euros
pour l'hôpital mignot du chesnay
rocancourt ça n'a pas amélioré la
situation du moins pas encore peut-être
voilà je pense que c'est une question de
temps par exemple pour ouvrir des lits
pour la pédopsychiatrie on a énormément
de jeunes adolescents hospitalisés avec
des grosses détresse les locaux vides
sûrement par la détresse de nos jeunes
beaucoup d'enfants qui se retrouvent
trois quatre jours dans des lits aux
urgences en attendant une place ça il
est évident pour construire des
structures de soins pour la
pédopsychiatrie ça sera pas en 2022 en
2023/2024 ça c'est vraiment une
politique au long terme l'augmentation
des salaires n'a pas suffi et ne suffira
pas je pense qu'en proposant 180 euros
par mois en plus nos collègues ne se
sentent pas valorisé par rapport à tout
le travail qu'ils font sans compter
leurs heures donc c'est une politique
plus globale et peut-être que les
français ont leur mot à dire dessus
peut-être qu'il faudrait un grand
référendum de la santé que les gens
prennent conscience de l'importance de
l'hôpital c'est le pilier de la santé
l'hôpital c'est à dire que si l'hôpital
s'effondre les gens pourront parce qu'à
soigner dernière question est ce que
vous avez pu rencontrer votre direction
est ce qu'une rencontre est prévue dans
les prochains jours avec votre direction
alors les rencontres ont lieu tout le
temps là le la mobilisation de vendredi
elle n'est pas elle est indépendante de
tout collectif ou syndicats elle est
complètement apolitique ins et voilà
notre direction écoutent mais notre
direction n'a pas tous les moyens de
recruter des infirmières évidemment on
aimerait mieux qui est plus
d'infirmières sur un secteur de soins
bien sûr quand vous avez quatre cinq
charnières pour pour je ne sais pas 30
ou 40 malades c'est pas suffisant ça
c'est pas de propos seulement de la
direction je pense que c'est une
politique générale l'augmentation de
recrutement dans les services pour bien
travailler mieux travailler et continuer
à prendre en charge non non non les
français de manière adéquate merci
docteur catherine à z man d'avoir été
avec eux dans ce journal
pédiatre au centre hospitalier de
versailles dans l'actualité également la
manifestation des anti vaccin appelé
plus communément les a sentis vagues ce
samedi à versailles il était environ 300
réunis devant l'hôtel de ville une
mobilisation en plein travail
parlementaire sur la transformation du
pass sanitaire en passe vaccinale adopté
par les députés le projet de loi était
étudié ce lundi par les sénateurs
également quelques jours après les
propos d' emmanuel macron qui a dit dans
une interview vouloir je cite emmerder
jusqu'au bout les non-vaccinés
la loi sur le pass vaccinale qui suscite
en ce moment beaucoup de tension après
l'adoption à l'assemblée nationale la
députée de la 5e circonscription des
yvelines il ya une brawn peavey a révélé
avoir été victime de menaces de mort
elle a reçu à sa permanence du vésinet
un courrier manuscrit d'une rare
violence qu'elle a relayé sur twitter
c'est également via le réseau social que
le préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot
lui apporter son soutien un signalement
qui se rajoute à une centaine de faits
de violence ou de menace déjà recensés à
l'encontre des élus de l'assemblée
nationale plusieurs enquêtes sont
ouvertes et sont en cours
[Musique]
c'était très attendues dans le sud
yvelines le centre aquatique de
rambouillet a rouvert samedi dernier
après cinq années de travaux l'espace
s'est largement agrandi et de nombreux
équipements ont été ajoutés margot jésus
et bixente magnas entité ban le centre
aquatique de rambouillet enfin rouvert
ses portes samedi dernier après cinq ans
de rénovation l'espace est désormais
plus grand et mieux équipés on a doublé
les espaces on a construit un bassin de
50 mètres avec une vraie modularité et
on a refait tous les bassins existants
les bassin d'apprentissage le bassin de
25 mètres avec un pont mobile c'est une
vraie une vraie renaissance du centre
aquatique les yvelinois attendaient avec
impatience cette réouverture
et ils ne sont pas déçus c'est magique
c'est un vrai bonheur on a attendu ça
depuis très longtemps donc on est
vraiment très content les travaux ont
pris un peu plus de plus de temps que
prévu donc oui on l'attendait et ça fait
vraiment plaisir de voir de l'avoir
ouverte ces espaces permettront aussi
d'accueillir les sportifs on et aires de
jeux 2024 on a été labellisé donc on est
dans les rangs pour pouvoir accueillir
l'entraînement et des équipes de shell
international qui viendront pour les jo
2000 24 ici sur rambouillet on est prêt
les accueillant les bassins extérieurs
sont encore en travaux ils seront
inaugurés en juin prochain une bonne
nouvelle pour la saison estivale
miquel et demi d'euros aux journalistes
sport de la rédaction de tv 78 ans
rejoint en plateau bonsoir ministre avec
vous on fait un petit tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département du football pour commencer
avec la coupe des yvelines ont joué à ce
week-end les huitièmes de finale de la
coupe des yvelines dans le match qui
opposait plaisir à rosny-sur-seine ce
sont les plaisirs oies qui ont réussi à
se qualifier pour le prochain tour
victoire avec 4 1 après avoir été mené
1-0 l'écoutent le capitaine de l'équipe
on avait à coeur de commencer bien 2022
on savait que en coupons c'était notre
domaine de prédilection
si on a fait un grand parcours en coupe
de france on s'est fait éliminer par une
3e penalty et donc la huitième de finale
il fallait qu'on remporte ce match on
savait que c'était un match éliminatoire
butoir donc on a fait un match assez
prolifique en buts avec 4 buts à notre
actif
et dans les autres rencontres que s'est
il passé alors on l'a vu un plaisir
s'est imposé 4 1 à domicile contre rosny
sur seine dans les autres rencontres
chatou s'est imposé 1 0 sur la pelouse
de houille même score pour villennes
orgeval sur le terrain de chambourcy
voisin écrase bailly noisy sur le score
de 6 à 2 conflans s'impose 1 à 0 face à
rambouillet enfin les mureaux s'impose
dans le derby 1 à 0 face à l'équipe 3 du
fc mantois match spectaculaire entre
marly-le-roi et hardricourt 3 à 2 pour
les mariés choix le match entre trappe
et gargenville a quant à lui était à
reporter sur cette animation voilà on
peut le voir avec la thématique qui
cacha effectivement vous en parliez
michael le match entre trappe la réserve
de trappes et d'argent ville qui a été
donc reportée du volley ball à présent
alors toujours en cours mais cette fois
ci en coupe de france de volley ce
samedi à 8 janvier le club de conflans
andrésy jouy recevez mende qui évoluent
en ligue b une division plus haut que
les yvelinois et d'ailleurs et l art
hiérarchie je vais y arriver a été
respectée les joueurs du département se
sont inclinés lors de ce deuxième tour
de la compétition le score 3 sets à 1 le
caj volley ball va maintenant se
reconcentrer sur le championnat élite le
club est pour l'instant la troisième
place après neuf journées en rugby dans
le championnat de fédérale 2 le match
entre plaisir et gennevilliers a
finalement été reportée au dimanche 13
février à cause de plusieurs cas de kobe
de 19 dans les effectifs les plaisirs
war reste donc à la huitième place du
classement après 11 journées disputées
la course automobile et cette
compétition légendaire qui se tient en
ce moment légendaire c'est bien beau
livre noir jean pierre garcin participe
actuellement au dakar 2022 il est le co
pilote de lionel baud chez ph sport à
bord d'une peugeot 3008 ils sont pour
l'instant 50e du classement général mais
la compétition n'est pas terminée
l'homme qui totalise 23 participations
paris dakar veut terminer la course dans
le top 50 on lui souhaite bon courage
pour la suite de l'épreuve le dakar se
terminera ce vendredi 14 janvier merci
michael michael et demi d'euros vous
retrouvez bien sûr ce soir aux manettes
du 7-8 sport pour tout savoir de
l'actualité sportive dans le département
des yvelines première diffusion bien sûr
ce lundi soir en direct à partir de
18h30 et en parlant de sport l'événement
se tiendra du 12 au 16 octobre prochain
pour la deuxième fois de sa jeune
histoire le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines accueille les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste et la billetterie pour ces
mondiaux vient d'ouvrir les places à la
journée elles vont de 16 à 50 euros
selon le secteur un pass pour les cinq
jours de compétition existe également
compter entre 80 et 100 95 euros les
infos sur le lien qui s'affiche en 2015
pour rappel le rendez vous s'était tenue
à guichet fermé 25000 spectateurs au
total sur les cinq jours de rendez vous
avaient pu assister aux sept médailles
d'or aux sept médailles dont 5 en or il
y avait eu cinq médailles en or est 2
l'équipe de france de cyclisme sur piste
dans la cité du cheval les sapins se
ramasse en calèche il ya six ans maisons
laffitte a fait le choix d'opter pour ce
procédé et les habitants y adhèrent
puisque des centaines de sapins sont
collectés chaque jour pendant une
semaine le reportage de mélanie potiche
l'attelage se prépare doucement ce lundi
10 janvier les quatre boulonnais les
deux percherons sont à nouveau sur le
pont depuis le vendredi 7 janvier les
équipages ramasse les sapins de noël on
les choisit pour l'heure pour leurs
aptitudes déjà physique puisqu'ils se
sont des chevaux qui sont un petit peu
plus costauds sont des chevaux de trait
donc qu'ils sont un petit peu plus
costaud que la moyenne pour tirer des
charges relativement lourde quand même
avec les sapins son équipe et des
remorques tout cela et puis surtout pour
l'heure leurs capacités mentales qui
sont des animaux froid très très bien
dans leur tête et qui sont des vrais
compagnons et des collègues de travail
de tous les jours trois attelages se
répartissent les différentes rues de la
ville selon les secteurs c'est la
sixième année consécutive que la mairie
fait le choix de ce type de ramassage on
faisait d'une pierre deux coups parce
que d'une part on collecte avec les
chevaux d'autre part après avoir broyé
les sapins on utilise le broyat dents
les espaces verts de la ville ce que
l'on a constaté c'est une augmentation
d'année après année où les gens se sont
fait à ce procédé et il apprécie
énormément les attelages travaillent
environ cinq heures par jour en une
heure cet équipage composé de trois
couches et de deux chevaux ont déjà
récupéré près d'une centaine de sapins
et ne laisse pas les habitants à
sensible pour sa bien d'une part parce
que les gens jettent pas leur sapin
d'impôt retrouve je trouve ça très bien
que ce sport gagne vite et je pense que
c'est que c'est une trop dur très bonne
idée c'est écologique voilà j'espère que
c'est pas trop lourd pour les joueurs
c'est tout à maisons laffitte le
ramassage continue jusqu'au 11 janvier
l'an dernier les équipes avaient
récupéré deux mille sept cents arbres la
collecte devrait être du même niveau en
culture pour refermer ce journal à la
commanderie de saint quentin en yvelines
à elancourt le photographe nicolas henry
s'expose jusqu'au 6 mars et des
portraits réussis à l'esthétique proche
de la peinture mais aussi des mises en
scène théâtrales célia gars de 100 go et
bixente maria santisteva des draps qui
bouge des chaînes qui symbolise la
justice et trois marins qui porte
secours à naufragés c'est la
scénarisation choisi par le photographe
nicolas henry pour évoquer le drame des
migrants en méditerranée un cliché
réalisé sur l'île de gorée au sénégal
c'est une photographique fictionnel mais
figurative un peu à la manière d'un
peintre en fait je suis posé une sorte
de cheval oeil à l'intérieur je vais
construire tout l'image il navré à
découvrir jusqu'au 6 mars à la
commanderie des templiers à elancourt
dans le cadre de l'exposition cabane
imaginaire et esprits de la nature
quinze ans de voyages à travers le monde
présentée au public avec une démarche
similaire lors de chacune de ces
rencontres évoqué l' intime et le mettre
en scène en utilisant la matière
première présente sur place le moment de
la photographie c'est un moment qui est
très important pour moi parce que c'est
un moment de représentation comme on n'a
pas l'impression tran qui va nous
raconter
monde l'exposition se poursuit également
en extérieur et dans le choeur de la
chapelle de la commanderie ici se
dévoile une nouvelle fois des clichés
qui pourrait rivaliser avec des toiles
signées des maîtres de la renaissance
la manière dont on a placé ses
photographies contemporaines mais qui
sont présentés comme les peintures
anciennes en fait ça s'intègre et ça
crée vraiment un projet scénographique
je pense car entier
[Musique]
homme de théâtre nicolas henry a aussi
réalisé des films d'animation en lien
avec l'écologie cause qui lui tient à
coeur il fait lui-même ses cadres photos
avec des encombrants et utilise du bois
de récupération
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]